avant que la vidéo commence j'ai une
question à vous poser vous croyez
vraiment que les gens ont lu tous les
livres dont il parle bien sûr que non
sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de grand
chose
eh oui il y a 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
[Musique]
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets savez vous avez lu
Ronan comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'il les applique les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet il brille par leur
culture dans les conversations et dans
les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver dix fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit tranquille sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo c'est
l'histoire de 10 secondes donc faites-le
maintenant et vous pourrez découvrir le
premier secret qui vous attendra bien
aux choses dans votre boîte mail après
avoir regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je
vous ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire
je vous laisse regarder la vidéo et moi
je vais promener Aristote
[Musique]
première référence vie de Zénon Diogène
la herse
imaginez la scène j'ai donc fait
fouetter un de ces esclaves qui a commis
un vol et comme le malheureux connaît un
peu la philosophie du maître il se
justifie en lui disant mais c'était mon
destin de voler et la Zénon lui répond
c'est aussi ton destin d'être fouetté
c'est une des nombreuses anecdotes que
l'on peut lire à propos de Zénon le
fondateur du stoïcisme dans les vies et
doctrines des philosophes illustres de
Diogène la herse qui est un écrivain
grec du début du troisième siècle son
livre qui est la référence pour les
biographies des penseurs de l'Antiquité
est également une référence
incontournable pour le stoïcisme parce
qu'il raconte la création de cette école
philosophique à travers la biographie du
fondateur après la biographie de Zenon
Diogène fait un exposé général des
doctrines stoïciennes qui est assez
technique et pour tout dire peu
éclairant
que retenir de la vie de Zénon tout
d'abord il ne faut pas le confondre avec
un autre Zénon le fondateur du stoïcisme
s'appelle les Zénon de Citium une ville
de l'île de Chypre et non pas et non
délai un philosophe présocratique et qui
vivait deux siècles plus tôt Diogène
raconte la légende de la conversion
entre guillemets de Zénon à la
philosophie appartenant à une famille de
riches commerçants xénon importe
notamment un colorant pourpre de
Phénicie le Liban actuel un jour il fait
naufrage avec la cargaison à Athènes
dans la capitale grecque et il entend un
libraire à lire de la philosophie et lui
demande où sont les hommes qui
enseignent cela pile à ce moment le
philosophe cratesse passe devant lui le
libraire dit alors à Zénon c'est lui
qu'il te faut suivre Zénon devient le
disciple de Cratès il conclut en vérité
ce naufrage m'a conduite à bon port
après Zénon changera de maître parce
qu'il n'aime pas l'imputeur des
philosophes cyniques son premier maître
cratesse en était un lorsqu’un oracle
lui dit qu'il doit entre guillemets
fréquenter les morts et non comprend
qu'il doit lire les classiques en fait
il n'avait pas attendu ce conseil pour
s'y mettre parce que son père lui avait
rapporté de ses voyages des ouvrages
d'auteurs de l'école socratique donc en
réalité Zenon était déjà initié à la
philosophie avant de s'installer à
Athènes ils fonde son école sous un
portique de l'Agora d'où le nom de
l'école le grec ancien Stoa signifiant
portique il fonde cette école dans un
des endroits les plus populeux de la
ville ces disciples sont d'abord appelés
zenoniens parce que les stoïciens sont
les poètes qui exercent sous le portique
comme Platon comme Aristote Zénon
enseigne selon la méthode dite
péripatéticienne c'est-à-dire qu'il
parle en déambulant ça a notamment
l'avantage de décourager les simples
curieux un peu misanthrope Zénon n'aime
pas la foule et puis il faut le payer
pour avoir le droit de le suivre
maintenant que retenir des idées de
Zénon à croire Dieu jeune la herse Zénon
enseigne surtout par l'exemple sa vie
quasi ascétique donne une grande
légitimité morale à sa philosophie et
favorise son expansion plus précisément
Zenon incarne une valeur fondamentale du
stoïcisme la résistance il faut résister
aux tentations à la facilité à la
souffrance Zénon est extrêmement
endurant au point que les Athéniens
emploient l'expression proverbiale plus
endurant que Zénon il est également très
frugal il se contente d'un régime simple
petit pain miel et un peu de vin dans sa
pièce les philosophes le poète grec
Philémon se moque de Zénon en disant je
cite qui l’enseigne la fin après Diogène
montre que la vie de Zénon n'est pas
100% exemplaire il lui arrive d'être
ivre il n'est pas insensible à l'argent
il en reçoit beaucoup du roi de
Macédoine Antigone gonathas et il fait
des investissements et comme d'autres
philosophes il aime les jeunes garçons
ce qui pour nous relève de la pédophilie
et enfin pour parler sans détour il
passe pour un donneur de leçons de
morale qui EMMERDE les gens
une autre dimension importante de
l'enseignement de Zénon c'est la
limitation de la parole à un jeune
vantard il dit la raison pour laquelle
nous avons deux oreilles mais seulement
une bouche c'est pour que nous écoutions
plus et que nous parlions moins là aussi
Zénon montre l'exemple en se taisant
souvent et en s'exprimant surtout de
manière brève et sans tensionieuse ce
qui contraste avec l'éloquence cultivées
dans les autres écoles philosophiques de
l'époque cette particularité s'explique
par son histoire personnelle il est un
demi barbare qui parle un Grec à peine
correct quand il s'installe à Athènes
enfin Diogène la herse précise aussi
mais ce n'est pas crucial que Zenon aime
le savoir il a une solide formation
intellectuelle il s'est entraîné à
débattre et il est prêt à payer cher
pour qu'on lui apprenne quelque chose
en se fondant sur ce livre on peut dire
que l'empreinte de Zénon sur le
stoïcisme est double tout d'abord il en
fait une philosophie pratique
c'est-à-dire qu'être stoïcien s'est
adopté un certain mode de vie se
conduire d'une certaine manière au
quotidien zenons impressionne tellement
ses contemporains par sa maîtrise de soi
Katan lui rend des honneurs publics à
plusieurs reprises et puis la seconde
dimension de l'influence du fondateur
sur le stoïcisme c'est que le mode de
vie c'est ici repose essentiellement sur
la modération voir sur le refus du
plaisir c'est en partie une question de
différenciation comme on dit en
marketing Zeno au fond de son école 5
ans après kepicure a fondé la sienne et
il le concurrence avec un message plus
radical hostile à la relaxation
deuxième référence vie de Cléante
Diogène la herse je viens de vous parler
de Zénon c'est un homme très austère et
ça semble difficile d'aller plus loin en
termes d'austérité et pourtant son
successeur à la tête de l'école
stoïcienne Cléante réussie à le
surpasser c'est encore Diogène la Hertz
qui nous raconte l'essentiel à connaître
sur ce philosophe dans ses vies et
doctrines et des philosophes illustres
que retenir de la vie de Cléante on ne
sait pas grand chose de ses origines
c'est un pugiliste c'est-à-dire un
boxeur qui est arrivé à Athènes avec
quatre drames en poche autrement dit il
est très pauvre étant donné sa pauvreté
il doit travailler beaucoup travailler
il doit encore trouver le temps de se
mettre à la philosophie concrètement il
puisse de l'eau dans les jardins la nuit
et il s'exerce au raisonnement le jour
le seul moyen qu'il trouve pour prendre
en note les cours de Zénon et décrire
sur des tessons et des omoplates de bœuf
il est surnommé le second Hercule parce
qu'il est une force de la nature qui ne
s'arrête jamais de travailler Zenon dit
à ce propos Cléante pourrait nourrir un
autre clé entre s'il le voulait
malgré son acharnement au travail jour
et nuit qui fait qu'il dort peu malgré
cela il est en forme les Athéniens
pensent qu'ils cachent quelque chose
donc il lui faut un procès bien sûr il
est acquitté et les juges impressionnés
par l'exemplarité de sa conduite décide
de lui allouer une somme d'argent
si Cléante est une force de la nature il
est en revanche peu doué
intellectuellement et très lent ce qui
lui attire les moqueries des autres
élèves de Zénon ça ne l'empêchera pas
d'écrire pas mal de livres même de beaux
livres selon Dieu Jenner Hertz et
surtout de succéder contre toute attente
azénon à la tête de l’école stoïcienne
enfin l'anecdote sur sa mort et
révélatrice de la dimension médicale de
l'alimentation dans l'Antiquité
dimension que nous avons malheureusement
en grande partie perdue Cléante est
atteint d'une gingivite une inflammation
localisée de la gencive les médecins lui
préconisent alors un jeune de deux jours
et ça fonctionne il guérit enthousiaste
Cléante décide de continuer le jeune
contre la vie des médecins et il meurt
de faim
maintenant que retenir des idées de
cléantes comme Zenon Cléante enseignent
surtout par l'exemple la première clé de
son exemple est bien sûr le goût de
l'effort qui est une expression
particulière de la résistance valorisée
par Zénon un jour clé entre un spartiate
qui lui dit que l'effort est un bien et
ça rend Cléante heureux de voir qu'il
n'est pas le seul à avoir compris cela
mais son goût de l'effort est vraiment
radical il dit qu'il préfère sa vie à
celle des riches qu'il préfère
travailler la terre plutôt que de jouer
à la balle ainsi la valeur suprême de
l'effort est liée à la vanité du
divertissement la seconde clé de son
exemple est l'humilité Cléante ne se
prend pas pour un surhomme c'est plutôt
le contraire il est timide ce qui lui
évite de commettre des erreurs et il
s'insulte lui-même son humilité implique
d’être indifférent à la critique ainsi
il encaisse les moqueries des autres
disciples stoïciens estimant que c'est
le prix à payer pour égaler la force
morale de Zénon autre exemple
intéressant
quand le poète ce Citéos l'insulte
devant tout le monde au théâtre Cléante
reste de marbre impressionné par cette
réaction les spectateurs l'applaudissent
et chassent le poète mais Cléante
accordera son pardon au poète quand
celui-ci éprouvera du remords enfin
comme pour le goût de l'effort
l'humilité de Cléante est radicale dans
le sens où elle est liée à la
condamnation de la recherche de la
gloire un homme qui lui demande conseil
pour son fils il répond un verre de
ripide silence silence que la trace de
tes pas soit légère
Cléante a également transmis ses idées à
l'écrit puisqu'il est d'après Diogène la
Hertz l'auteur de pas mal de livres les
hommes de l'antiquité qui ont pu les
consulter disent que le style de Cléante
est très imagé avec des allégories le
seul texte qui est arrivé jusqu'à nous
et l'hymnase en gros cléan te rendent
hommage à deux sont en co-cauteur et
régulateur de l'ordre du monde auquel le
stoïcien se soumet chose intéressante
Cléante demande à Zeus de permettre aux
hommes de comprendre comment ils
gouverne le monde et il lui promet alors
les hommes ne cesseront de le célébrer
en conclusion qu'elle aide à pas ce
livre l'empreinte de Cléon sur le
stoïcisme en premier lieu il alimente la
culture stoïcienne de la Résistance en
donnant un exemple radical d'une vie
entièrement consacrée à l'effort en
seconde lieu son hymne national se
divise l'ordre du monde le cours des
choses tout ce qui survient et l’œuvre
d'une divinité qui gouverne avec
clairvoyance et bienveillance c'est
pourquoi les hommes doivent t'aimer le
destin en même temps qu'il s'y
soumettent par là Cléante donne au
stoïcisme un côté religieux en
personnifiant l'ordre de la nature en un
dieu suprême et personnel auquel on
s'adresse avec émotion comme un père
Sauveur
troisième référence vie de crises
Diogène
705 livres d'après Diogène la herse
toujours dans ses vies et doctrines des
philosophes illustres crisip le
troisième dirigeant de l'école
stoïcienne aurait écrit au total plus de
705 livres pas besoin d'être
polytechniciens pour comprendre qu'il y
a un loup je vais vous donner la
solution de ce mystère dans les
prochaines minutes et je fais également
vous expliquer en quoi il est
emblématique de l'influence de crédit
dans le stoïcisme
que retenir de la vie de crédit tout
d'abord c'est crises de soles une cité
grecque du sud de la Turquie actuelle
comme beaucoup des élèves des écoles
philosophiques de l'Antiquité il est un
fils de bonne famille mais on raconte
qu'il se serait mis à la philosophie
parce que son héritage a été saisi pour
alimenter le trésor royal après ce n'est
pas clair est-ce qu'il s'est mis à la
philosophie par dépit ou bien est-ce que
la perte de son héritage ce qui arrivera
également à Sénèque le plus célèbre des
philosophes stoïciens est-ce que ce
revers de fortune lui fait comprendre
qu'il doit s'entraîner à résister à
l'adversité en tout cas il devient le
disciple de clairante deux de ses
caractéristiques se manifestent dès sa
formation il est doué pour les idées et
il est arrogant il n'hésite pas à
contester l'autorité intellectuelle de
Cléante qui n'est pas brillant
intellectuellement comme on l'a vu comme
son maître crisible est un bourreau de
travail mais un travail intellectuel il
passe son temps à écrire ce n'est
possible autrement on pourra coucher de
plus de 700 livres il est très
discipliné il couche 500 lignes chaque
jour bien évidemment quand on écrit
autant on écrit mal dieu de la herse dit
que le style de crisip est bâclé et puis
sur le fond il se répète beaucoup et
pratique le bourrage de citations c'est
sophisme sont médiocre Apollo d'or
d'Athènes un grammairien grec du
deuxième siècle avant Jésus-Christ dit à
ce propos si on retire les citations
étrangères des livres de crises il ne
restera plus que des feuilles blanches
crisip tient également des propos
controversés comme de comparer les dieux
à des prostituées ce qui était risqué à
l'époque de défendre l'inceste et le
cannibalisme
malgré cela beaucoup de ces livres
jouissent d'une grande notoriété en même
temps dans le lot il y en a forcément
qui doivent plaire
sur le plan du mode de vie crise zip
n'est pas du tout exemplaire comme xénon
et cléantes il incarne certes la sagesse
stoïcienne par certains aspects il est
capable d'être absolument impassible
lorsque les esprits s'échauffent ou
encore ils pratiquait la course à pied
avant de se mettre sérieusement à la
philosophie aujourd'hui la course à pied
passe un peu pour un exercice stoïcien
parce que l'endurance est une forme de
résistance mais crisip n'est pas du tout
exemplaire par d'autres aspects il est
loin d'être aussi modéré que c'est long
il n'a pas l'humilité de Cléante il est
au contraire arrogant il prétend par
exemple être le meilleur maître de
philosophie enfin crisip n'est pas
fidèle à l'école stoïcienne comme
d'autres disciples après la mort de
Zénon ils rompt avec le stoïcisme il
rejoint l'Académie l'école fondée par
Platon pendant un temps avant de revenir
à l'école stoïcienne il a 45 ans quand
il succède à Cléante
maintenant que retenir de ses idées il
ne reste presque rien de ces 700 livres
donc il est difficile de répondre à
cette question à quoi certains auteurs
ultérieurs crisibles seraient
l'inventeur de certaines images qui
illustrent la morale stoïcienne comme la
comparaison de la vie avec une course
qu'il faut essayer de gagner avec
fair-play d'après ce que dit Diogène n'a
enrichi l'enseignement stoïcien ni par
ses discours ni par son exemple en
revanche il a bien laissé une empreinte
sur le stoïcisme il l'a intellectualisé
les deux premiers fondateurs et non et
cléantes avaient certes une activité
intellectuelle mais la manière de
conduire leur existence était une
dimension essentielle de leur
enseignement en comparaison crisip et
plus un écrivain qu'un sage d'ailleurs
d'après d'autres témoignages il
redéfinit la philosophie comme la quête
du savoir rationnel
et quatrième référence traiter des
devoirs Cicéron
Jules César qui est dictateur perpétuel
est assassiné en 44 avant Jésus-Christ
les sénateurs qui avaient préparé le
coût n'avait pas prévenu si c'est rond
parce qu'ils savent qu'il est très
anxieux seulement la réaction publique
n'est pas celle que les meurtrières
avaient prévu donc il fuit Rome si c'est
rond lui se retire dans une de ses
villas pour voir comment les choses
évoluent il écrit à son fils un manuel
de morale qui le guidera toute sa vie ce
traité des devoirs est une référence
incontournable du stoïcisme parce qu'il
transpose la morale stoïcienne au monde
romain Cicéron n'est pas lui-même un
stoïcien il est affilié à l'Académie de
Platon mais son traités est un guide
moral stoïcien il dit au début du traité
que ce sont les stoïciens qu'il faut
écouter pour connaître les devoirs de
l'homme
quels sont les idées principales de
cette référence le traité est divisé en
trois livres le premier explique comment
agir pour l'honneur le deuxième commande
agir pour atteindre un but et obtenir un
avantage et enfin le troisième dit
comment résoudre le conflit entre
l'honneur et l'avantage les deux
premiers livres sont inspirés par la
philosophie du stoïcien panettius de
Rhodes qui est le fondateur de ce qu'on
appelle le moyen stoïcisme qui désigne
la renaissance du stoïcisme à Rome au
deuxième siècle avant Jésus-Christ le
troisième livre est davantage l'oeuvre
de Cicéron lui-même
dans le premier livre Cicéron mettant
lumière le lien entre la vérité et la
sagesse il faut connaître la vérité se
renseigner efficacement pour être sage
il faut notamment connaître la nature
afin ainsi que le préconise les
stoïciens de pouvoir vivre en accord
avec elle si c'est ronds étant la thèse
stoïcienne en ajoutant que la nature
inclut la nature humaine l'individu doit
donc élaborer un idéal de vertus qui
s’aligne avec sa nature personnelle plus
généralement en tant que membre d'une
communauté il doit être utile à son
prochain cela demande de ne pas se
laisser perturber y compris par le
succès si ces ronds reprend l'idée
stoïcienne classique selon laquelle il
faut pratiquer la modération en
soumettant ses impulsions à la raison
mais la vertu n’empêche pas de chercher
à obtenir des avantages dans le deuxième
livre du traité Cicéron explique qu'il
est nécessaire d'avoir durablement bonne
réputation afin de gagner la confiance
de ses semblables et la meilleure
manière d'y parvenir c'est de poursuivre
un objectif noble avec intelligence et
honnêteté mais quoi faire lorsque la
vertu et l'avantage sont en conflits le
point de départ de la réponse de Cicéron
et la nature sociale de l'homme le
bien-être de l'individu dépend de celui
de son groupe par conséquent il se nuit
à lui-même si une nuit à son prochain
Cicéron illustrent cette idée avec
l'image de la course de fonds de crises
il faut donner le meilleur de soi-même à
la course sans empêcher autrui de faire
de même par exemple en faisant un
croche-pied la conclusion est une action
ne peut pas être avantageuse sans être
vertueuse puisque l'immoralité nuit à
celui qui est immoral lorsque le bon
choix n'est pas évident il faut examiner
la moralité des conséquences si elles
sont contraires à la vertu alors il faut
renoncer à l'action si ces ronds donnent
l'exemple du consul romain Régulus fait
prisonnier par Carthage non seulement il
conseille aux Romains de ne pas les
changer contre des Carthaginois qui ont
une valeur militaire supérieure à la
sienne et en plus il tient sa promesse
de revenir en tant que prisonnier à
Carthage après l'échec des négociations
quel est l'empreinte du Traité des
devoirs sur le stoïcisme comme je vous
l'ai dit au début ce traité est
emblématique de la transposition de la
morale stoïcienne au monde romain après
les premières heures du stoïcisme la
ferveur initial était retombée la
doctrine était trop théorique pour les
Romains des deux derniers siècles avant
Jésus-Christ qui était avis de préceptes
pratiques il voulait en même temps une
spiritualité qui était absente du
stoïcisme mais qu'il trouvait chez
Platon et Aristote deux philosophes pas
nés dessus de Rhodes et sont disciple
positonius ces philosophes ont adapté le
stoïcisme aux mentalités ils en ont fait
une morale pratique purger des détails
dogmatiques ils ont propagé l'habitude
de la réflexion morale et de l’examen de
conscience ce moyen stoïcisme pénètre en
partie grâce à Cicéron les divers
milieux de la société romaine il devient
même sur le plan politique un foyer de
résistance aux despotisme des empereurs
en tant qu'école de pensée indépendante
refusant de pratiquer les cultes imposés
par le pouvoir
référence numéro 5 de la brièveté de la
vie Sénèque la société a privilégié ces
mecs il est né dans une famille aisée et
influente à Rome mais la nature elle ne
l'a pas privilégié sa santé est fragile
au début de la vingtaine il tombe
gravement malade au point qu'il doit
repousser l'entame de sa carrière
politique il part en Égypte dont il
pense que le climat l'aidera à se
rétablir il en reviendra au bout de
plusieurs années mais il aura des
problèmes de santé toute sa vie il subit
par exemple des crises d'étouffement qui
peuvent durer jusqu'à une heure cela lui
donne certainement une conscience aiguë
du temps qui passe dans la jeunesse avec
un corps neuf vit comme s'il était
éternel mais la fragilité du corps qui
se révèle avec les années impose la
conscience de la mortalité tout cela
finira un jour
cet essai de la brièveté de la vie et le
livre de référence sur la condition
humaine dans le stoïcisme et comme son
titre l'indique il traite de la
condition humaine à travers le prisme du
temps qui passe et de la conscience de
la mortalité
et qu'elle s'adresse à son beau-père
pollinus le point de départ de son
propos c'est que les hommes perdent leur
temps dans d'illusoir conquête ou de
futile loisirs leur vie s'écoule comme
un chemin qu'il parcourt sans le voir
perdu dans leur pensée c'est vrai pour
les hommes les plus puissants et pour
les plus sages comme pour la masse des
hommes ordinaires ils sont égaux sur ce
point tous ils se lamentent que la vie
est trop courte et en cela il se trompe
tous en réalité la vie est bien assez
longue le problème est réside dans
l’emploi du temps c'est parce qu'il
gaspille la vie en avarice en travaux en
inaction en intrigue en conquête en
combat etc que les hommes ont
l'impression de manquer de temps
tout homme très occupé ému par
l'ambition à en réalité une condition
misérable c'est pourquoi ces
recommandations beau-père pollinus de ne
pas se laisser absorber par sa carrière
publique la raison principale de ce
gaspillage c'est que le temps n'est pas
une ressource tangible comme de la
nourriture ou de l'argent ce qui abuse
écrit Sénèque c'est que le temps est
chose impalpable qui ne frappe point les
yeux et l'on en tient fort peu de conte
je dirais presque il n'a aucun prix on
le jette à pleine main il semble ne rien
coûter
quelle est la solution il faut tout
d'abord traiter son propre temps comme
la ressource qui a le plus de valeur
rien en dernière instance ne vaut
suffisamment pour être échangé contre le
temps il est non seulement disponible en
quantité limitée mais il n’est pas
renouvelable il faut dès lors
l'économiser avec un soin extrême pour
ce faire il faut regarder le passé avec
recul habiter le présent et ne pas
attendre c'était dire ne pas différer de
vivre Sénèque recommandent de vivre
chaque jour comme toute sa vie afin de
ne pas appréhender le lendemain et de se
mettre ainsi à l'abri du sort
la conscience du temps qui passe est de
notre propre mortalité nous amène à un
certain mode de vie celui du sage
Sénèque considère que le sage est le
seul qui sache vraiment vivre car il
donne son temps au seul vrai loisir il
défriche la vie pour les générations
suivantes comme les précédentes l'ont
fait pour lui en donnant ainsi comme un
ami la richesse de ses pensées par
l'intermédiaire de son œuvre il ouvre
les perspectives et le temps en
dessinant une vie qui ne périt point il
est une porte vers l'immortalité la
sagesse est donc elle seule à l'abri du
temps qui passe
ce livre n'est pas l'ouvrage de Sénèque
le plus influent dans le stoïcisme mais
il a tout de même été influent à deux
titres en premier lieu il fait prendre
au courant une direction athéiste et
matérialiste c'est par exemple comme ça
que Diderot qualifie le stoïcisme dans
l'Encyclopédie c'est facile à comprendre
si je dois éviter de dépenser mon temps
n'importe comment cela signifie que
c'est l'ici et maintenant mon existence
quotidienne dans le monde matériel qui a
de la valeur et non pas une hypothétique
vit après la mort on peut même voir dans
cette vision de l'existence une des
racines de l'individualisme moderne en
préservant son temps on est centré sur
soi-même et on travaille à son bonheur
individuel
en second lieu de la brièveté de la vie
marque également le stoïcisme sur le
plan de la forme le style
particulièrement clair de Sénèque rend
la lecture facile et agréable ce qui a
bien sûr constitué un avantage
considérable pour diffuser les idées
stoïciennes si les Occidentaux du début
du 21e siècle s'intéressant au corps au
sol icimes Élise encore Sénèque c'est
grâce à la clarté de son style
référence numéro 6 de la vie heureuse
Sénèque
Descartes passent pour le père de la
pensée scientifique moderne mais il
s'est également intéressé à l'éthique ou
à la morale si on veut c'est à dire à la
manière dont les hommes doivent se
conduire et en la matière laissez de
céder qu'intitulé de la vie heureuse est
une des références de Descartes il le
commente d’ailleurs dans ses fameuses
lettres à la princesse allemande
Elizabeth de bohème de la vie heureuse
est une référence incontournable dont le
stoïcisme parce qu'il fournit la
définition du bonheur stoïcien comme
l'indique le titre les spécialistes de
Sénèque disent aussi que ce sont ces
réflexions morales les plus abouties
elles étaient destinées à son frère aîné
l'homme politique romain galion
quand retenir sur le fond Sénèque
définit le bonheur à partir de l'idée
fondamentale du stoïcisme l'accord de la
volonté avec l'ordre de la nature on a
tort d'envier à autrui l'éloquence la
richesse le réseau et la puissance car
ce sont des biens extérieurs qui sont à
la vie heureuse ce qu'un mur plaqué de
matériaux brillant est à une maison d'un
intérieur grossier Sénèque part de la
situation de l'homme ordinaire cet homme
n'a pas la recette de la vie heureuse il
désire le bonheur sans jamais se
demander en quoi il consiste puisqu'il
ne le définit pas il part forcément dans
la mauvaise direction et là Sénèque nous
met en garde contre ce que les
psychologues appellent la preuve sociale
nous ne trouverons pas la vie heureuse
en nous contentant de faire comme tout
le monde rien et christineck n'a plus
d'importance que d'éviter de suivre
comme le font les moutons le troupeau de
ceux qui nous précède nous dirigeons non
pas où il faut aller mais où il va la
multitude la foule et je cite le pire
interprète de la vérité malheureusement
quand il s'agit de conduire son
existence chacun préfère adopter des
croyances par lesquelles il est
contaminé plutôt que d'exercer son
jugement or on ne peut pas être heureux
sans exercer son jugement
mais comment être heureux précisément
tout d'abord il ne faut pas rechercher
le plaisir Sénèque et critiquent la
conception du bonheur d'Épicure auquel
il refuse même le titre de Sage le
problème avec le plaisir c'est que la
quête de la jouissance conduit l'homme a
privilégier le corps aux dépens de l'âme
or cette préférence est incompatible
avec la vie heureuse car le plaisir est
instable tandis que le souverain bien se
caractérise par son immutabilité en
cultivant le plaisir on sacrifie sa
liberté et les jouissances les plus
grandes se changent même en douleur
l'erreur fondamentale des épicuriens
c'est de confondre le plaisir et la
vertu une chose agréable n'est pas
forcément morale
la richesse tant qu'on s'est enrichi
honnêtement qu'on s'entraîne à redevenir
pauvre qu'on est facilement généreux et
qu'on ne place pas son cœur dans ses
trésors ni dans sa dignité d'homme riche
que dire concernant l'influence de ce
livre sur le stoïcisme pour faire simple
il règle le rapport du stoïcisme à
l'ascétisme c’est-à-dire l’idéal et où
le mode de vie visant à satisfaire le
moins possible les instincts de la vie
animale beaucoup d'écoles philosophiques
de l’antiquité tendaient vers la
séthisme mais la position du stoïcisme
restait à préciser Sénèque est dans une
position particulière pour répondre
parce qu'il est l'homme le plus riche de
son temps ça lui est d'ailleurs très
reproché de donner des leçons de morale
et de prôner la résistance stoïcienne du
haut de son immense fortune il est donc
directement concerné par la question et
en arrière-plan de cette question il y a
l'enjeu de la cohérence entre les
paroles et les actes le mode de vie de
Sénèque est-il compatible avec la
philosophie qu'il professe
sa réponse à deux effets sur le
stoïcisme première effet en prenant un
certain rapport à la richesse plutôt
qu'en la condamnant il contribue à
légitimer la participation des stoïciens
à la vie sociale ils ne sont pas des
sages vivants à l'écart de la cité ils
peuvent être des hommes d'action en
revanche ils doivent profondément
méditer leur action
second effet de la réponse de Sénèque
sur le stoïcisme en condamnant le
plaisir dans la première partie de
l'essai Sénèque clarifie et entérine la
distinction entre le stoïcisme et
l'épicurisme il existe de véritables
points communs entre les deux sagesse ce
qui explique que des disciples passés
d'une école à l'autre il existe de
véritables points communs mais la
polémique de Sénèque en fait deux
visions du monde incompatibles
[Musique]
référence numéro 7 lettre à Lucie Lius
de Sénèque
à la fin de la vingtaine je lisais une
des lettres de Sénèque à lucidiieux ce
chaque matin en buvant mon café l’idée
derrière ce rituel et c'était de me
conditionner dès le début de la journée
pour aborder mon existence avec
détachement c'était plutôt efficace je
ne suis plus ce rituel aujourd'hui parce
que ma routine matinale était devenue
trop compliquée elle doit rester simple
pour durer cette anecdote illustre ce
qui fait des Lettres à Lucilius une
référence incontournable pour le
stoïcisme c'est le meilleur exemple
d'applications pratiques de cette
philosophie
Erasme un des plus célèbres humanistes
de la Renaissance qui a traduit les
œuvres de Sénèque Érasme aime les
lettres parce qu'elles offrent un reflet
fidèle d'une situation réelle
quelle est cette situation conseillé de
l'empereur romain Néron après en avoir
été le précepteur Sénèque tombe en
disgrace en 62 il demande la permission
de se retirer totalement de la vie
politique en vain car sa présence est
requise pour conserver l'appui des
sénateurs après qu'un complot contre
l'empereur échoue en 65 un découpable
affirme que Sénèque était indirectement
favorable à l'entreprise Sénèque ni mais
il ne convainc pas Néron qui lui ordonne
alors de mourir
Sénèque écrit les lettres hallucilius
pendant les quelques mois qui précède
son suicide contraint cette situation
donne à sa parole une profondeur inédite
il s'adresse à Lucilius un ami de longue
date un homme d'origine modeste qui
s'est élevé jusqu'au plus haute fonction
politique pour l'encourager à mener une
vie philosophique selon les principes du
stoïcisme
quelles sont les idées essentielles des
lettres à lucidius on retrouve tout
d'abord sous une forme simplifiée la
définition de la sagesse stoïcienne par
le détachement le stoïcien place son
bonheur dans ce qui dépend de lui c'est
sa raison qui lui permet de vivre
conformément à la nature la véritable
liberté et qui vaut au consentement à la
soumission à l'ordre naturel ensuite il
y a quatre thèmes essentiels plus précis
dans les lettres premier thème essentiel
l'amitié Sénèque reprend la distinction
d'Aristote entre l'amitié d'intérêt et
l'amitié authentique comment reconnaître
la seconde par le niveau d'engagement
que la relation commande on est capable
de suivre le vrai ami en exil de prendre
des risques mortels pour lui il faut
donc bien choisir ses amis à un
véritable ami on fait autant confiance
qu'à soi-même on est totalement
transparent avec lui même si l'usage
veut qu'on garde certaines choses pour
soi mais ne devient-on pas dépendant du
véritable ami s'il faut bien cultiver
l'amitié puisqu'il est naturel d'avoir
des amis il faut conserver son
indépendance c'est-à-dire rester capable
de se tenir compagnie à soi-même
deuxième thème essentiel des lettres la
vieillesse Sénèque a pris conscience de
sa propre vieillesse en constatant celle
de la villa de campagne qui l'avait bâti
de ses mains la dernière phase de la vie
n'est pas la pire parce qu'on y est
désormais libre des passions qui sont un
peu les illusions de la jeunesse le
grand charme de la vie écrit Sénèque est
à son déclin lorsqu'il n'est pas encore
brutal il recommande de considérer
chaque nuit comme une petite mort il
donne même un rituel au moment de se
coucher se dire à soi-même avec
satisfaction et même avec joie qu'on a
bien vécu jusque là troisième thème
essentiel des lettres la préparation à
la mort Sénèque reprend la célèbre
définition déjà donné par Platon de la
philosophie comme préparation à la mort
le sage stoïcien ne ressent pas
l'angoisse de la mort car la fin est
toujours proche pour l'homme qui ne
l'oublie pas c'est pourquoi le temps qui
passe ne change rien à ce rapport à la
mort et puis se préparer à mourir c'est
la soumission la plus essentielle à
l'ordre des choses enfin il y a aussi un
bénéfice psychologique l'homme de sa
mortalité jouit bien plus de la vie cet
effet se produit chez les gens qui
apprennent que leurs jours sont comptés
à cause d'une maladie grave
quatrième thème essentiel des lettres la
nécessité de pratiquer la philosophie
Sénèque enjointe à lucieuse de faire de
la philosophie un entraînement quotidien
la sagesse n'est pas dans les discours
elle se mesure dans l'action tout
particulièrement dans la réaction aux
accidents qui jonchent l'existence il
faut agir selon les valeurs stoïciennes
de la modération qui se traduit dans la
frugalité et de la résistance qui se
manifeste notamment dans le travail
perpétuel Sénèque donne l'exemple en
restant très actif dans sa retraite il
travaille tard le soir et s'endort même
à la tâche il suit le précepte stoïcien
selon lequel la mort doit nous
surprendre en pleine action
il y a en tout 124 lettres donc il y a
encore d'autres thèmes par exemple
Sénèque évoque le rapport au temps ou
l'influence nocive de la foule quelle
est l'influence de ces lettres dans le
stoïcisme pour faire simple elles font
du stoïcisme une philosophie pratique
Sénèque méprisent les philosophes qui se
contentent de jouer avec les mots la
véritable philosophie consiste à adopter
un mode de vie déterminé par des
exercices concrets et la meilleure
manière d'enseigner des exercices
concrets c'est par exemple longue et la
voix des préceptes courtes et
infaillible celles des exemples écrit
Sénèque dans la lettre numéro 6 ce n'est
pas un hasard si le stoïcisme a resurgi
au début du 21e siècle a l'air
d'Internet comme un courant de
développement personnel les auteurs
américains de best-seller qui parlent
des lettres hallucilius ne se plonge pas
dans Platon Aristote ou Kant c'est trop
chiant à lire et cela ne permet pas
d'améliorer concrètement l'existence
les lettres hallucilius sont si
accessibles que leur influence dépasse
largement le stoïcisme et la philosophie
sur le fond elles ont beaucoup influencé
les intellectuels du moyen-âge où elles
étaient une des rares sources
disponibles sur le stoïcisme de
l'antiquité ensuite les idées éthiques
de Sénèque ont beaucoup influencé les
humanistes de la Renaissance et les
philosophes des Lumières sur la forme la
tonalité personnelle et l'absence
d'ordre du propos font des lettres
hallucilius un des principaux modèles du
genre moderne des essais dont les Essais
de Montaigne sont le type accomplis bref
les lettres hallucilius ont eu une
énorme influence dans la culture
occidentale c'est d'ailleurs un des
livres de philosophie les plus lus
huitième référence le manuel d'eptets
l'étymologie grecque du nom Épictète
épictetos signifie serviteur c'est tout
simplement parce que Pictet a commencé
dans la vie comme esclave on raconte
qu'il avait un maître brutal voire cruel
un jour se mettre veut essayer un
instrument de torture et il se dit tiens
si j'essayais sur la jambe d'Épictète un
homme ordinaire se sauverait en courant
mais Epictète lui prévient son maître en
souriant qu'il va lui casser la jambe et
lorsque ça arrive il ajoute simplement
je vous l'avais dit n'est-ce pas cette
anecdote est peut-être une légende mais
elle montre que la résistance est
vraiment une valeur cardinale du
stoïcisme
le manuel des Pictet est une des plus
célèbres sources du stoïcisme c'est un
résumé constitué par un disciple des
cours que le philosophe donnait à
Nicopolis des pires sur la côte centre
ouest de la Grèce actuelle l'objectif
était en faire un compagnon permanent un
livre qu'on est toujours sur soi et
qu'on puisse consulter en toute
circonstance simplissus un philosophe
des cinquième et 6e siècle après
Jésus-Christ dit du manuel que je cite
c'est une arme de combat qu'il faut
toujours avoir à sa portée et dont il
faut que ceux qui veulent bien vivre
soit toujours prêts à se servir la
pensée dépictète est également
accessible via ses entretiens mais cette
source est moins fiable parce que le
disciple le même qui a compilé les cours
le disciple a reconstitué les dix
entretiens de mémoire certains estiment
qu'il les aillent imaginer
que retenir du Manuel d'Epictète ce sont
des maximes s'adressant à un jeune
disciple qui n'est pas encore philosophe
le livre commence avec la formule culte
du détachement il y a des choses qui
dépendent de nous il y en a d'autres qui
n'en dépendent pas il faut plus
précisément distinguer d'une part les
choses libres au sens où elles dépend de
nous où elle nous appartiennent ce sont
notamment les jugements les tendances
les désirs les aversions et d'autre part
les choses servent au sens où elles ne
dépendent pas de nous et ne nous
appartiennent pas vraiment ce sont
notamment le corps la richesse la
célébrité ou encore le pouvoir pour
Épictète cette distinction est la clé de
la liberté et du bonheur mais afin d'y
arriver il faut pratiquer le détachement
à l'égard de tout ce qui ne relève pas
exclusivement de l'âme concrètement pour
se détacher d'une chose il faut la
ramener mentalement à sa réalité
matérielle la dépouiller de tous les
sentiments qu'on y a investi et puis
peut-être reprend également la thèse
stoïcienne classique de l'accord avec la
nature ne demande pas dit-il que ce qui
arrive arrive comme tu veux mais veuille
que les choses arrivent comme elles
arrivent et tu seras heureux autrement
dit une fois que l'on est soumis au
destin on ne le subit plus il ne peut
plus nous affecter et puis peut-être
reprend aussi la définition très
classique du philosophe par la maîtrise
de soi enfin il dispense pas mal de
conseils de sagesse à la fois précis et
pratique comme par exemple la nécessité
de se lancer dans un projet après
l'avoir médité avec réalisme puis de s'y
consacrer entièrement sans se disperser
la nécessité de s'exprimer avec
parcimonie en évitant la vulgarité et en
ménageant les sentiments des
interlocuteurs conseils qui rappellent
le laconisme de Zénon ou encore la
nécessité de limiter les soins du corps
à la plus stricte utilitaire tous ces
conseils sont intéressants mais ils ne
sont pas particulièrement emblématiques
de la sagesse stoïcienne
le manuel se termine avec une idée plus
stoïcienne qui renvoie à l'exemplarité
des deux premiers fondateurs Zénon et
cléantes pour Épictète la philosophie
n'est pas une science mais un mode de
vie encadré par des principes de sagesse
il précise même que l'application des
Maxime de sagesse et la première étape
de la philosophie
quelle est l'importance de ce livre dans
le stoïcisme il est probablement le plus
important tout court si on me demandait
un seul livre à lire pour découvrir le
stoïcisme c'est celui-ci que je
conseillerais sans hésiter en fait il
porte bien son titre parce que c'est le
seul véritable manuel c'est-à-dire un
livre qui est instruit le lecteur sur un
sujet en synthétisant l’essentiel le
manuel d'epypet et le seul véritable
manuel du courant philosophique qui est
le stoïcisme et contrairement à beaucoup
de manuels de philo le propos est très
accessible très clair souvent concret au
point que cela ressemble pour nous à ce
qu'on appelle du développement personnel
ce n'est pas un hasard si le stoïcisme
et si le manuel des big têtes sont
revenus à la mode sur Internet
dans le détail des idées l'empreinte de
ce livre sur le stoïcisme tient
essentiellement à la distinction de ce
qui dépend de nous et de ce qui ne
dépend pas de nous c'est une méthode
intellectuelle précise pour atteindre
l'indépendance émotionnelle après
l'influence du manuel d'epithète ne se
limite pas au stoïcisme ces idées sont
notamment passées dans la tradition
chrétienne où elles ont servi à définir
certains modes de vie de l'ascétisme
chrétien comme celui des ermittes du
Mont Sinaï ou encore la règle de
Saint-Benoît un genre de constitution
pour la vie monastique rédigé au sixième
siècle le manuel a également eu une
influence littéraire il a été traduit
plusieurs fois en français dès le 16e
siècle et il a notamment fait une
profonde impression sur Pascal
9ème référence les pensées pour moi-même
de Marc Aurèle
le film Gladiator met en scène
l'empereur romain Marc Aurèle en prenant
des libertés avec la réalité historique
son fils Commode qui lui a succédé a
bien été un tyran mais il n'a pas accédé
au pouvoir en assassinant son père au
contraire ils ont exercé le pouvoir
ensemble pendant plusieurs années à la
fin du règne de Marc Aurèle de même le
film fait passer Marc Aurèle pour un
sage et pris de justice sociale alors
qu'il était un conservateur en effet
pour un stoïcien la révolution est
intérieure psychologique tandis qu'à les
garder des choses extérieures il faut se
soumettre à l'ordre naturel ces pensées
pour moi-même qui sont son journal
intime qu'il a tenu en bonne partie
pendant ses campagnes militaires ce
journal intime est une référence
incontournable pour le stoïcisme parce
qu’il est emblématique de l'effort
spirituel du philosophe stoïcien en
tenant un journal intime marquerelle et
dialogue avec lui-même comme l’indique
le titre afin d'examiner sa conduite et
d'imprégner saâme des principes et des
valeurs du stoïcisme comme je vous l'ai
dit à propos de Sénèque le technicien
est un homme d'action mais il est
crucial qu'il médite sur son action
quelles sont les idées essentielles des
pensées pour moi-même en premier lieu
elle présente le stoïcisme comme un mode
de vie Marc Aurèle s'estime heureux de
ne pas être venu à la philosophie par un
mauvais chemin celui de l'éloquence de
sophistes de l'érudition ou de l'étude
de la nature pour autant il reconnaît
qu'il a du mal à vivre comme un
philosophe stoïcien mais comment faire
Marc Aurèle donne la même réponse que
les générations précédentes de stoïciens
bien vivre consiste à agir en accord
avec la nature cela demande notamment
d'abandonner ses croyances concernant le
bien et le mal car elles sont de mauvais
guides pour l'action par exemple la mort
et la vie la gloire et l'obscurité la
douleur et le plaisir la richesse et la
pauvreté touchent autant les bons et les
méchants elles ne sont donc ni des biens
ni des mots
une autre idée essentielle est
l'importance de la Justice Marc aurait
affirme qu'il s'agit d'une des exigences
fondamentales de l'éthique stoïcienne or
le contenu de cette exigence dépend de
la définition de la Justice Marc Aurèle
reprend la conception socratique de la
justice comme harmonie des parties dans
le tout il voit plus précisément
l'univers community dont tous les êtres
rationnels sont des concitoyens de même
que la cité attend de ses citoyens une
certaine conduite l'univers attend des
hommes qu'il se comporte d'une certaine
manière ainsi l'homme doit se comporter
de façon à contribuer au bien-être de
l'humanité toute entière Marc Aurèle
défend donc une forme d'altruisme
c’est-à-dire une idée de la morale selon
laquelle bien agir consiste
fondamentalement à agir dans l'intérêt
de nos semblables les autres êtres
humains concrètement c'est altruisme
passe par des actes simples le stoïcien
doit donner de la nourriture à une
personne affamée plutôt que d'essayer de
la convertir au stoïcisme en la
persuadant de résister à la fin Marc
Aurèle estime que la proportion de
l'individu a coopérer avec ses
semblables pour le bien de la communauté
appartient à la nature humaine on
retrouve donc le refrain stoïcien de la
vie conforme à l'ordre de la nature
autre idée essentielle des pensées pour
moi-même Marc Aurèle insiste sur
l'importance de l'impassibilité c'est à
dire la capacité à ne pas se laisser
affecter c'est un autre mot pour parler
du détachement de l'indépendance morale
du sage l'importance de l'impassibilité
se justifie par une conception
déterministe du monde pour marquerelle
le cours des choses n'est pas le fruit
du hasard chaque événement est l'effet
d'une cause laquelle est elle-même
l'effet d'une cause antérieure
l'évolution du monde se décompose en une
chaîne de causalité autrement dit
survient dans l'univers survient par la
nécessité le stoïcisme de marquerelle
inscrit donc l'homme dans un destin dont
les événements sont programmés et donc
prévisibles on n'en sait pas plus dit
Marc Aurèle en ayant observé la vie
humaine pendant 10 000 ans que pendant
40 ans l'ordre des choses auxquelles
appartient la nature humaine l'ordre des
choses ne change pas donc il est absurde
de s'étonner du cours des événements et
de réagir émotionnellement
maintenant quelle est l'influence des
pensées pour moi même sur le stoïcisme
ce livre n'est pas original sur le plan
des idées son influence tient
essentiellement à la pratique c'est un
exemple exceptionnel de mise en
application de la philosophie stoïcienne
autant s’ennex et vu reprochés de ne pas
faire ce qu'il dit par exemple il était
très occupé alors même qu'il
recommandait de ne pas s'immerger dans
des projets ambitieux autant le mode de
vie de Sénèque paraissait peu cohérent
avec ses idées autant la vie de Marc
Aurèle semble cohérente avec ses
discours ses actes expriment la sagesse
stoïcienne jeune adolescente il décide
de dormir à même le sol malgré sa santé
délicate devenu empereur il accepte de
partager le pouvoir il met aux enchères
ses propres bien pour financer la
défense de l'Empire romain il annule les
dettes de simples citoyens il améliore
plus généralement la condition des
pauvres et des esclaves et enfin exemple
les loquant il meurt de l'épidémie qui
décime son armée si ce que Nassim
Nicolas Taleb appelle le skin in the
game assumer soi-même le risque que l'on
fait prendre aux autres
bref les pensées pour moi même sont le
témoignage le plus emblématique de
l'accord entre la pensée stoïcienne et
la vie concrète des hommes comme Zenon
cléantes ou Épictète ont certes été
exemplaires et ils ont vécu en accord
avec la philosophie stoïcienne mais
quand on a l'Empire romain à gérer c'est
une autre histoire
enfin les pensées pour moi-même ont
également popularisé l'exercice
d'écriture qu'est la tenue d'un journal
intime d’ailleurs cet exercice est
parfois associé à la sagesse stoïcienne
dans l'imaginaire collectif cet exercice
à divers bénéfices psychologique
notamment mais le bénéfice mis en
évidence par le journal de Marc Aurèle
c'est de pouvoir agir de manière
réfléchie de diriger consciemment ces
actes de mener son existence un peu
comme un général mène son armée avec
Marc Aurèle le stoïcisme est on ne peut
plus une philosophie de l'action mais
l'action obéit à la pensée à la
méditation
dixième référence consolation de la
philosophie boes
en 525 le philosophe est politique latin
boes est arrêté puis mise en prison à
Pavie au nord de l'Italie le roi des
astrogotes Théodoric dont boes et
l'intime ont plus en être le conseiller
théodorique l'accuse d'être impliqué
dans une conspiration
boesclave son innocence en vain pour
supporter sa chute de la meilleure
condition à la pire il se raccroche à la
culture philosophique dont il a été
nourri dès l'enfance il écrit donc la
consolation de la philosophie en prison
sans le secours d'aucun livre
cette référence n'est pas une oeuvre
strictement stoïcienne boes évoque à
plusieurs reprises le stoïcisme et
certains penseurs stoïciens mais il ne
s'identifie pas lui-même comme un
stoïcien malgré cela il y a plusieurs
raisons qui justifient de faire figurer
la consolation de la philosophie dans le
top 10 du stoïcisme tout d'abord les
circonstances de la rédaction de ce
livre sont emblématiques d'une des
valeurs cardinales si ce n'est de la
valeur cardinale du stoïcisme la
résistance la situation de boss fait
d'ailleurs penser à celle de Sénèque qui
écrit les lettres hallucillius pendant
les quelques mois qui précède son
suicide contraint autre raison qui
justifie de relier la consolation de la
philosophie au stoïcisme les idées
essentielles sont évidemment
d'inspiration stoïcienne boes s'inspire
également de Platon mais dans une
moindre mesure dernière raison
importante enfin ce livre a contribué à
la transmission des idées stoïciennes de
l’antiquité romaine à la période qui
commence au 9e siècle dite scolastique
parce que la production intellectuelle
est concentrée dans le système
académique ique lié à l'église médiévale
le mot scolastique vient du latin
scolastiqueus qui désigne au Moyen-Âge
le chef d'une école ecclésiastique
maintenant que retenir de ce livre sur
le fond boes personnifie la philosophie
en une femme à laquelle il se plaint et
pose des questions et en retour elle lui
tient un discours qui vise à le consoler
d'où le titre du livre c'est-à-dire à
soulager son profond chagrin plus
précisément la philosophie veut rendre
Boyce plus résistant lui qui allâme
troublé par un grand revers de fortune
il a l'impression que les innocents
souffrent les peines que méritent les
méchants tandis que ceux-ci les méchants
font impunément tout ce qui leur plaît
l'inconstance de la fortune et le
triomphe du crime rendent donc
nécessaire la résistance seulement la
poésie n’est pas la solution elle
entretient la douleur et ne fait
qu'accoutumer le cœur aux mots qui le
dévore en exprimant des sentiments
frivole qui étouffent la raison c'est la
philosophie qui donne à l'homme les
armes qui doivent le rendre invincible
et même plus il y a d'obstacles à
vaincre plus il gagne en sagesse l'homme
sage a d'autant plus besoin d'être
résistant qu'il est la cible naturelle
des méchants ainsi que le montre
l'histoire de la
Socrate xénon ou encore Sénèque ont par
exemple souffert de persécution mais la
philosophie élève un rempart contre la
méchanceté fut-elle celle d'un tyran
l'homme qui sait supporter tous les
événements et toujours heureux boes
retrouve la valeur de la résistance
stoïcienne mais comment être résistant
la femme qui incarne la philosophie
répond la même chose que les stoïciens
il faut se soumettre à l'ordre des
choses boss affirme à travers la voix de
la philosophie personnifiée sa foi en un
ordre naturel immuable créé par une
intelligence suprême et conduit par elle
avec sagesse cette intelligence suprême
est Dieu malgré cette Providence les
hommes sont sans cesse le jouet de la
fortune celle-ci peut rendre le même
individu misérable et heureux en moins
d'une heure si boes souffre c'est donc
parce qu'il a oublié l'inconstance de la
fortune il a également méconnu le fait
que les biens appartiennent à la fortune
pas un individu seulement l'avidité des
hommes est sans limite ils ne savent pas
se contenter des richesses j'ai dit
dignité que Dieu leur prodigue de ce
point de vue les revers de la fortune
ont un avantage l'homme comprend que le
véritable bonheur ne réside pas dans les
richesses ou les dignités alors où le
véritable bonheur réside-t-il dans la
vertu comme Sénèque boys commence par
réfuter la conception ordinaire du
bonheur le bonheur ne réside pas dans
les biens de ce monde car l’homme ne lui
possède jamais ensemble c'est pourquoi
il souffre forcément du manque il y a
même des effets pervers par exemple les
richesses rendent les hommes encore plus
cupides et plus méchants de même les
hommes les plus puissants sont les
esclaves des passions qui les dévorent
intérieurement l'homme doit donc
abandonner l'illusion que les biens de
la fortune le rendrontent heureux et
simplement suivre ses besoins c'est la
vertu qui le rendra heureux pour cela il
faut acquérir la puissance intérieure
qui consiste à régner sur soi-même en
dominant c'est passion boes développe
une idée qui me plaît beaucoup la
distinction entre la puissance
intérieure et la puissance extérieure un
tyran à certes la puissance mais écrit
boes il est en proie à 1000 tyrans
inférieurs en vertu de quoi il est
profondément malheureux en comparaison
l'homme sage vit peut-être dans la
misère mais il a la puissance intérieure
il règne sur lui-même il domine ses
passions de la sorte il se possède
lui-même si bien qu'il ne pourra jamais
rien perdre et que rien ne pourra
troubler la profonde paix dont il jouit
boes retrouve là la fameuse idée
stoïcienne du détachement quelle
influence cette référence a-t-elle lu
sur le stoïcisme sur le plan de
l'histoire des idées comme je vous l'ai
dit la consolation de la philosophie de
boes a contribué à transmettre et
diffuser les grandes idées stoïciennes
au philosophes et théologiens de la
période fertile du Moyen-Âge en effet
boes écrit à une période du cinquième au
9e siècle une période entre guillemets
vide sur le plan de la production
intellectuelle les invasions barbares
empêchent le prolongement de la culture
classique et la division de l'Empire
romain disperse les éléments de cette
culture ainsi la consolation de la
philosophie et la seule oeuvre
philosophique notable de l'époque
ensuite cette référence promeut la
valeur stoïcienne de la résistance par
les circonstances de sa rédaction passer
de la richesse et du pouvoir à la prison
est un des pires revers de fortune qu'un
homme peut connaître en liant les idées
du stoïcisme à ce contexte humain
exceptionnel la consolation de la
philosophie donne à ses idées une grande
résonance
enfin comme boes ne présente pas son
discours comme stoïcien alors que ce
discours est stoïcien en son fond et
qu'il le présente comme le discours de
la philosophie elle-même il contribue à
assimiler et on peut même dire à réduire
la philosophie au stoïcisme son livre
contribue donc à donner aux idées
stoïciennes une importance prépondérante
parmi les idées philosophiques mais sans
les étiqueter comme stoïcienne cette
réduction de la philosophie a certaines
valeurs stoïciennes notamment fait
penser à l'expression française avec
philosophie accepter son sort avec
philosophie prendre les choses avec
philosophie ou encore apprendre une
nouvelle avec philosophie c'est faire
preuve d'une fermeté d'âmes d'une
résistance morale typiquement stoïcienne
alors la vidéo vous a plu j'espère que
oui si vous ne l'avez pas fait je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez découvrir les
cinq secrets pour vous cultiver dix fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo croyez-moi
faites-le et vous me remercierez
[Musique]